after weeks of insisting the show must
go on now something of a turnaround from
the Japanese Prime Minister we've hoped
to hold the games to mark that the world
has defeated the coronavirus I thought
that canceling them is not an option at
all but if that becomes difficult we
will think of the athletes first and
foremost and we may have no options but
to consider postponing the games are set
to be held in July but the virus that's
caused both human catastrophe and
economic crisis across the globe is
threatening the world's biggest sporting
event Canada became the first country to
announce its Olympic and Paralympic
teams won't be participating in the
games urging the International Olympic
Committee and the Tokyo organizers to
push back the event by at least a year
we're witnessing a remarkable upsurge in
athletes speaking out against the
International Olympic Committee who has
been very slow to act in the face of the
coronavirus situation and in that sort
of leadership vacuum you've seen
athletes and sport bodies rise up and
what Canada has done just moments ago is
absolutely remarkable
Tokyo's Olympic Chief has warned that
the game's billion dollar budget and
years of planning are at stake and that
cancelling would be bad for both
stakeholders and athletes they'd seen
over there go you we never intend to
talk about a cancellation but Japan and
International Olympic Committee will
talk together about what to do
postponement will only be one of the
many scenarios the increasing pressure
from athletes to call off the games is
not just because bringing hundreds of
thousands of sportsmen and women coaches
and fans together could help spread the
virus but they argue that having them
continue high-level training as putting
them and their families at risk I think
I think it's it's the best option is the
least worst option available to us now
so they've got an amazing opportunity
here to perform the games and then bring
the world together after we see the back
of this bonus just a few weeks ago the
idea of postponing the Olympics was and
think
now it's looking more and more likely
another victim of these unprecedented
times the IOC says it will make a
decision within the next four weeks for
now the Olympic torch relay is set to go
ahead from Thursday but without the
usual fanfare with crowds urged not to
attend alexei o'brien al jazeera